yeah so i tested positive yesterday for
well it was left from last thursday but
got the results back
bex and i both went and got the blood
test for covid
19. and the results were both were
positive for both of us for the
antibodies
right right so you don't have to i don't
have an active infection now
i had it back in and this makes total
sense now so i'm just going to lay out a
timeline because
initially i got tested and we thought it
was negative i'm explaining why
so back in march march 16 17 ish
i started having a fever and other
symptoms right very light cough light
fatigue
pretty serious fever it was i've never
had a fever for eight days before
i mean i i i've had bad fevers remember
back when i had hand foot and mouth
disease back in 27 oh my god you
couldn't even like get up and walk out
the door
yeah yeah but that lasted a couple days
and then it broke that was even higher
fever
but um this fever just stretched on and
maybe even been 10 days total because i
think i
probably didn't start taking my
temperature for a couple days yeah and
so i had a fever for
well over a week yeah and you wouldn't
got tested well i sort of got tested so
i went to doc green and this was a time
when tests were really really
scarce and so what they were doing at
the time
the current belief was you could not
have a co-infection
and so what they did is they tested you
for other viruses first
and so i test a positive for the human
rhinovirus which is a cold virus right
yeah and so if you test positive they
didn't want to waste the
the sars cov2 reagents that's a reagent
is what it takes to
test the the the the same so because so
their belief was you can't have the cold
and cov2 at the same time that was the
current belief at the time
that has since been proven false that is
not factual
wow and so uh the good news is i didn't
end up having to pay for that first test
which thank goodness oh
good it was like a 500 test yeah and
the the reason i i was willing to pay
that much for that test at the time is i
was separated from my family
right because i i had symptoms bex had a
slight cold but she didn't have the
similar symptoms as me and
so we stayed separate from each other
for over a week because of this and
finally got the test results back and
they were like well you can't have a
co-infection so you're all good to go
well turns out that's not true yeah
and so i and it makes sense now because
the human rhinovirus is not
gonna it's a it's a cold it's a common
cold you're not gonna have a fever for
eight days
right nine days ten days with a common
cold
and so uh back in march i had
the chronovirus i had covet 19 and this
test by the way
is 99.9 accurate uh and the way they
know that and this was done through
labcorp by the way if you want to do a
test i don't
get anything for tell you telling you
this but um if you're interested
uh our friend adam lam is the the guy
who i bought it from
they're relatively expensive now i think
they're just over 100 bucks 149 or
something
well it's yeah relatively inexpensive
compared to a 500 yeah compared to where
what it was
um so okay so let's talk about why this
test is 99.9
percent accurate i'm gonna do that so uh
sean put a link to it in the show notes
it's just a renewliferx.com
covid if you want a a test for yourself
they'll send you to a local
lab core and and then you get your blood
drawn
like like normal and then it takes about
three days to get the
two to three days to get the results
back i believe and so the reason this
test is effective is they took a bunch
of blood samples
prior to the proliferation do they come
to your house and do that
i don't know if they can or they can't i
went to a lab you went to 11 yeah
um and and so they
they tested a bunch of samples that
existed before the
spread of sars cov2 and
they tested for false positives right
so i don't get it okay so let's say you
had your blood drawn back in
july of last year okay you could test
that blood
can i absolutely but do they still have
that blood
yeah yeah a lot of these places okay so
so the clinic you went to they had blood
samples from
from you lab core has lots of blood
samples oh
i see what you're saying they have
results and they can tell with
so they don't even need your blood as
much as they can no they went back and
test the blood
and so so lab core holds onto your blood
i don't know if lab core does or doesn't
but
um or if you give permission to or
whatever but you got your test
and they compared it to blood that they
had stored somewhere
no no no no that's not what i'm saying
okay so the way they test the accuracy
of the test
is they go back and look at blood
samples oh okay
they took 1020 blood samples okay and
they said we want to see what the false
positive rate on this test is
and i was thinking it was probably gonna
be ten percent yeah twenty percent even
right
um and they out of out of one thousand
twenty
uh samples one false positive came back
okay
and so it's a statistically viable
sample size that the test is over 99
i see accurate yeah so the way that they
the way that they
uh confirmed this test was going back
and testing a thousand and twenty
samples that they had exactly to make
sure there aren't a bunch of false
positives i see
now if they would have come back with
yeah there's 600 false positives well
then it's a
useless test or even if it was 500
400 whatever are you going to donate
blood now uh
i mean i could i guess if it was helpful
yeah i'd be happy to yeah
um and and so the reason i bring this up
is
i am immuno slightly immunosuppressed
i'm on a medication for crohn's disease
that i'm not severely immunosuppressed
and i'm not immunocompromised
necessarily i thought it would have
killed you honestly i was worried about
you getting it i was worried too that
that like it
something terrible could happen and
here's the thing it was not fun having a
fever for eight days having all these
symptoms fatigue etc
it was not bad but it was not nearly i
mean it wasn't it wasn't hand foot and
mouth disease which was far far far
far worse would you rather have covet
for eight days or hand foot and mouth
disease for three days
cover phrases no no question really it's
not even close okay for me
now right that that said hand foot and
mouth disease i'm sure
kills a certain amount of people every
year yeah um and
uh i dealt with it it was awful it was a
terrible terrible sickness back in 2017
and um kovid was like this is a pretty
bad cold
with a a slight fever so
fever never got above 101 i don't think
yeah which is still a fever i mean
i could feel it but it but the whole
point being is um
i'm i'm relatively healthy other other
than that medication i'm on
my diet is pristine my exercise is
pristine
and my my lifestyle has very little
stress and i
sleep a lot you know i you know seven
eight hours every night
and and i've removed many of the
stressors from my life